joining me now Clay Travis Fox Sports
host radio host author of the book
Republicans buy sneakers - clay I have
to say I I am both saddened but not
surprised that this is where it's going
given China's outsized influence now in
American Commerce and of course with the
money that the NBA is making over there
in China with franchise fees but man the
NBA has a lot of a lot to say about
Trump and what he does but seems like
they have no spine when it comes to what
happens in China it doesn't seem like
they have no spine Lauren thanks for
having me they have no spine when it
comes to what's going on in China this
is I believe the worst week that any pro
sports league has ever had in my life
because I know you've covered a lot of
this but the NBA bans the word owner
because they decide it's racially
insensitive they replace it ironically
enough for people who remember the civil
rights movement with the word governor
which actually has worse connotations in
some states given the way things have
gone they also decide that they're gonna
pull their all-star game out of
Charlotte North Carolina because of a
local state transgender bathroom law I
don't know about you are but I don't
think transgender people have a lot of
rights in China just like the entire
population of 1.4 billion people does
not have a lot of rights there Steve
Kerr was asked whether or not he was in
there basically of democracy and he
wasn't willing to endorsement democracy
in there he said America and China are
basically the same thing when a belief
which is not a laughably absurd I don't
even know what he could be thinking the
fact that Kerr could even approach
drawing a moral equivalency between a
country that has at least a million
Muslims in the equivalent of internment
camps they have no freedom can't move
political dissidents never heard from
again Christians persecuted every manner
of oppression and subjugation and that's
a gray area for mr. Kerr because
all mighty dollars involved and so this
is what I'm saying when these people
claim they care about all these social
justice issues and they get all offended
when someone even Nick's them with
criticism at home you know I'm calling
them on all of their you-know-what
because I think they care about one
thing
primarily they want to win but it's
about money so let's just say it's about
money than just we all know where we're
coming from now it's about money so you
know just lose the idea that you're all
about your moral principles give me a
break the whole thing is ridiculous and
another American company by the way clay
is now caving in to the Communist
Chinese Houston rocket Rockets
merchandise has reportedly disappeared
off the shelves of Nike stores in China
Reuters reporting that managers at five
Nike stores in Beijing and Shanghai say
they've been told in recent days via
memo from management that all Rockets
merchandise had to be removed now this
is the same company by the way that uses
Colin Kaepernick to represent them so
maybe the new slogan for Nike clay
should be believe in something as long
as Beijing approves we can brand it is
fantastic it had the irony on this is
mind-blowing because again these guys
have said over and over again LeBron
James for instance is trying to market
himself as the Muhammad Ali of his
generation more power to him for
marketing purposes
but Muhammad Ali actually went to prison
and fought against a war LeBron James if
he really wanted to take a stand could
right
he could say I believe that the 1.4
billion people in China deserve the
exact same rights that many Americans
take for granted freedom of speech
freedom to get on the internet without
censorship all these other issues but I
think a big part of this Laura growing
and going forward is China is moving and
this is important this is an important
distinction from hey if you want to play
the Avengers movie in our country we're
gonna edit two minutes of it but it's
for our country inside of the country
what they are trying to do now is they
are trying to propagate their communist
worldview into America and they are
using our sports leagues like the NBA as
a conduit to do it in the NBA
is allowing them to do it it's
absolutely pathetic that this is allowed
to be taking place yeah so clay it's
like they got rid of the nomenclature
owners for the actual owners of the
teams but then they transfer that
ownership to a communist regime so the
the owners now are far away in Beijing
whose tentacles reach right across the
ocean into the United States and into
the psyche and mindset apparently of
these players but I'm just glad this has
all been developed revelatory for us we
now know what everyone really stands for
and within the masks are off so I think
this is this is a sad moment but it's
very revealing I think to all of us like
thanks so much and coming